what up space fam goal sent here for
anime uproar and today I'm going to be
talking about how strong one of the
cutest girls in anime is if you enjoyed
these how strong videos then make sure
to smash that like button to let me know
and leave suggestions for what character
strengths you would like to see broken
down next just keep in mind I've already
discussed on judo and xeni too if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell so you actually
get notified when you demon slayer
videos drop for more demon Surtur
content and crucial updates about the
new movie and seasons follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
linked in the description
keep in mind there will be manga
spoilers in this video because we're
going to go over all of the evidence
available to pinpoint exactly how strong
the Zuko is now without further ado
let's jump into it Mitsuko started out
as a regular young girl who took care of
her even younger siblings but everything
changed will the demon Nation attacked
long story short Natsuko becomes a demon
however unlike most demons she learns to
control herself
soon after turning into a demon she
tries to protect hunch it off from gu
she's also special because she can
recover through sleep and doesn't need
to eat human flesh like other demons
obviously in the beginning she's no
match for the water pillar GU who
effortlessly takes her out without much
trouble however as with ton zero she
grows stronger as the series progresses
even from the beginning there's choirs
extremely powerful kicks and can easily
kick a demon's head off of its body
still though she needs to team up with
tons you know for them to defeat the
first demon they meet even though he's
relatively weak the next time we seen
Ezra Cole fight is after ton zero passes
the selection exam
she helps ton general fight against the
swamp demon she protects children while
time zero jumps into the swamp world and
one of the swamp demon clones can't help
the remark that musical is so strong the
demon suggests that Nessa ko has been
given a large amount of Mouzon blood and
as we know more Muslim blood usually
means more power The Swamp demon remarks
that even though she hasn't used her
blood demon art medical so quick that he
can't jump back into the swamp Meza KO
ends up eventually being saved by tan
Jiro who cuts the demon into pee
but still this battle was significant
because mezu ko is no longer someone who
always needs to be protected she can
also be useful in battle and help
protect others like Thanh general or
even other humans if it wasn't for her
Tundra would not have been able to
protect the children from all of the
clones later mezu ko helps time she to
fight against the red arrows demon and
the heavy balls demon she ends up
getting strong enough so that she can
kick the heavy balls back tamio even
comments on how no Zuko managed to make
herself stronger at an alarmingly fast
rate it must be something in the common
dough blood that gives these two
siblings explosive rates of growth
nevertheless the heavy balls demon girl
is really strong so Tamayo ends up
helping to defeat her the next time
those go shows off her skills is when
Rui
lower Moon five is absolutely wrecking
Thanh zero mezu ko uses her own body as
a shield to protect her brother for the
most part no Zuko just gets tortured by
the spider demons webs during this fight
but she does unlock her awesome blood
demon art blood burst this move causes
her blood to explode into hot flames the
plains are strong enough to burn Louise
webs and make tons of sword more
powerful to the point where he could
have cut off his head if the lower moon
didn't attach it himself first
both Tonto and Natsu Co are becoming
stronger and stronger with each fight
but at this point they need you to save
them from Ruiz strongest attacks on the
demon train medical uses her flames to
help wait time zero up she also helps
protect the humans from being digested
by lower Moon one fast forward to when
da key and upper moon is about to kill
ton zero and mezu ko kicks her away
sending her flying since da ki has the
highest concentration of Mulan's blood
out of any demon she's met yet da key
triggers as we close memories the
memories make Bezeq extremely angry
giving her a power boost da ki cuts
Nesbo's body up but to the upper moons
surprise medical quickly regenerates as
da key points out at this point
medicals regeneration speed matches that
of an upper moon then we see what
appears to be Nezzer clothes new form
she gains a horn flower tattoos and her
body goes through some serious puberty
in this form
she's so menacing that even doc he can
feel the pressure she
giving off she manages to kick da key to
the ground and her regeneration speed
even surpasses that of da keys then she
uses her blood burst ability to burn da
key da key has trouble healing from
these flames ethical begins to
completely overpower her but then
medical begins progressing too far into
a demon and it's about to attack a human
and ton zero must come in and stop her
power wise though he or she even
surpassed da key and up her moon and
keep in mind that upper moons are
supposed to be stronger than pillars to
be fair rocky is not an upper moon on
her own but only when combined with her
stronger brother still though Meza coal
was completely overpowering her and
surpassed the regeneration speed of an
upper moon the side guess that she's at
least a round pillar level at this point
though she can't fully control herself
then mezu KOA systems you know with
upper moon for wall she is fighting one
of the clones he can't help a remark
about nezu cos powerful kicks she
overcomes one and sends him flying away
but another one hits her with lightning
powers after tundra frees her she helps
protect ton zero by setting the
lightning clone on fire but then she
carries tons about the safety when three
clones gang up on that she goes on to
use her blood demon art to turn tunnels
black blade red the same color of your
teaches blade and since you eat she was
the strongest demon seen in history it's
safe to say that this new red blade is
much much stronger than tangelos usual
black one it's actually crazy how useful
mezco is she's like the anti Sakura from
Naruto she goes on saving tons you know
time after time and makes him
significantly stronger even while she
fights with a lot of power herself a per
moon for even says that the demon
meaning net Zuko was the worst of the
three brats she really got in his way
implying that she was stronger than both
ton zero and ganya during the majority
of this fight then when the Sun starts
coming out she even cakes ton Kjetil who
is covering her from the Sun towards the
upper moon to finish him off she is
ready to sacrifice her own life
luckily Mitsuko ends up being fine she
is now the only demon that is able to
survive in the Sun and she can even talk
now so she was clearly an Opie demon
before but now she's also the
want to ever conquer the Sun not even
musong could do that in Muslims view
because of her ability to withstand the
Sun desi cool surpasses all of the 12
demon moons in value and he refers to
her as the chosen demon
Muslim believes that if he eats and
absorbs our precious Natsuko he can
actually defeat the Sun mezu KO is
currently in bed and they are trying to
turn her into a human so that moves on
streams will fall apart I'd say that
before this Meza Cole was right there
with ton zero strength if not a little
stronger as doc you mentioned she was
like an upper moon during their fight
and we can assume that she got even
stronger during the fight against upper
moon for she was the one saving Tundra
most of the time in that battle as we
learned when mu Ichiro killed up her
moon 5 it is very rare for a pillar to
defeat an upper moon who usually keep
their positions for centuries
longer than the lifespan of pillars so
if mezu ko has achieved upper moon level
then it's safe to say that she is at
least pillar level and probably stronger
than some of the pillars and if she
continues to be a demon and continues
with her rapid rate of growth then
she'll just keep getting stronger
especially since the biggest demon
weakness the Sun no longer affects her
however the issue is that her growth has
been halted because she's in bed while
the others are fighting and growing like
I said I think tan judo and mezu Cole
were pretty close in strength and
ethical was probably stronger during the
upper moon for fight however since then
tan general has gotten a lot stronger
his fight against upper moon 3 Icaza
pushed him to the point where he not
only gained perfect mastery over to see
through world he also gained access to
his no self state which takes him to
supreme territory I'd say for the time
being he surpassed mezu KO but mezu KO
really shines no pun intended when she's
fighting alongside ton judo
she is consistently saving him helping
him unlock new powers and perfectly
complimenting him in any way he needs
together the two would now make a truly
formidable team rain or shine I really
hope that we get to see more fighting
from mezu KO because up to this point in
addition to being one of the cutest
girls in Shonen she's also been one of
the most useful anyways that's it for
this one thanks for watching
hope you enjoyed watching Nessa cools
amazing transformation from regular cue
girl to one of the strongest characters
and Demon Slayer make sure to smash that
like button if you did enjoy this video
and let me know whose strength you would
like to see broken down next if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you actually
get notified when new videos drop a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero to your patrons the
one and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson king zelgius angel Cruz
stealers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith pitied Allah beeped at
Karachi and Anatole Kazansky and DJ
Nathaniel and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stay atop all clans Stephen
and Radha
allo Lana 1090 Mac 239 makoto-kun and
seth cooper hashtag praise the sun if
you enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to
patreon.com/scishow uproar and becoming
a patron today for as little as $1 if
you do so you'll get your name featured
in future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
you
[Music]